good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast we are so excited like
literally I haven't slept all night
because we are sitting down with the
queen of Netflix's brand new show too
hot to handle Francesca Thank You
Francesca for being here thank you guys
for having me we love you we recap the
show on our show and we just really felt
like you were the protagonists that we
needed it's our understanding that this
show was filmed a little while ago is
that right
a year ago okay and your life has
changed yeah you got bangs
they're really long right now because
obviously good they do look good
Thanks so America fell in love with you
on this fabulous reality show we loved
watching it um the show made it seem
like you just kind of signed up for a
show that you thought was maybe like a
dating show hot people on the beach and
it turned out to be something else so
I'd be really curious what your
experience getting on the show was like
what was the audition process and what
did you think you were signing up for
okay so basically I was reached out to
via Instagram DM from one of the members
of production and she was just like hey
we have this new reality show on Netflix
we think you'd be perfect for it are you
interested you want to hop on a Skype
call
so all my friends were like no they're
gonna kidnap you and please don't do
this like they sent me some fremantle
which is the production company in the
UK they sent me some files and stuff
like that so I looked them up it looked
legit so I had a few Skype calls with a
few of the producers and they just asked
me what my stuff my sex life was like
they asked me about relationships best
dates worst dates about my Instagram DM
stuff like that and literally a few
weeks later I was on a plane to Mexico
so it was very very quick oh and so you
come to Mexico yeah it was Mexico yeah
how long how long were you guys filming
the show for cuz you guys were saying a
month but then it felt super quick it
was a month yeah Wow
and he really did some know people
mm-hmm and it was a month of everyone
sleeping in the same room I couldn't
believe that there weren't men in
women's quarters because most shows are
like that and they couldn't believe that
some people slept on the floor Bryce
yeah so they were so mean - Bryce they
no no
[ __ ] up their bed to share with Bryce so
that's why he had to sleep on the floor
so sad
Bryce like I had to share my locker with
him because no one wanted to give up
their locker I'm like you guys are evil
be nice to Bryce what house did they not
have enough lockers for everyone
well there was eight walkers yeah eight
walkers two showers two bathrooms that
were separate from the showers and then
the six-bed so I think at one point like
there was like 13 of us there so few of
us did have to sleep on the floor and
the lockers I think I'm not sure how it
was planned but I think they just wanted
us to see if there was drama what's
sharing the walkers like stuff like that
I got into a fight a bush with Sean
about Sheree and Walker he didn't want
to give up at his locker for Bryce so I
haven't dude I'm like come on girl I
have more [ __ ] than you like oh well
then I have another question about the
logistics because you guys had so many
days and so many bathing suits and I did
see some bathing suit sharing because
Chloe was wearing that one with the
lucite strap and then someone else was
wearing it and when you got into a fight
with Chloe
you said she was wearing your bathing
suit yeah so my closet was basically
open it was free game for the whole cast
and it was kind of like that with
everyone else's clothes as well so I
brought the most bikinis I probably
brought like 200 so where I let them use
them but I thought after we were arguing
that she she like don't talk to me I
didn't expect her to still wear my
bikini be like don't talk to me anymore
by the way I'm still gonna go into your
closet so your bikini I was like oh like
make sense but production did give us as
well I think there was like 10 swimsuits
that they brought in from a brand that
we are wearing that we were like kind of
communal and the girls kind of snag
those as well but yeah the costs are
basically being shared let me ride
sharing clothes was there a laundry
machine uh yeah so if we had our laundry
get to put them in a bag and we hung
them on our dressing thing and then
laundry was done every few days
interesting okay so we want to talk
about some of the friendships in the
house who do you still talk to and
aren't cool with so me and Hayley of
course are still friends we talk in love
Oh Hayley I'm sorry Harry as well I'm
good
our great and then I actually got closer
with Nepal and Chloe after filming and
stuff like that but everyone else like
we have a group chat and we talk every
day like everyone messages a group chat
saying Oh congrats on this or oh my god
I can't believe this person photos you
know stuff like that but I don't really
like I'm not as close with the rest of
the group and I don't think Harry easy
either like there was some stuff that
was hard to watch back and it just is
what it is like if you put ten people in
a house from all over the world like not
everyone's gonna get along so so
speaking of things that were difficult
to watch back you know I started the
show and I was like Francesca
ride-or-die and it was really
frustrating for me on that first kind of
bump in with you and Harry's
relationship is like he totally throw
you under the bus so did everyone else
and then like we never got justice like
we know for a fact Harry kissed you and
not only did he throw you onto the bus
he lied on your name and we never got
like a full circle was that edited out
have you guys spoken about that is that
still a point of contention um honestly
it was really hard because while I was
living it um what I was seeing was what
you guys saw for the water reveal so
when he was like oh that didn't happen
but he was kind of saying that stuff
under his breath so I didn't really hear
that either
like I just thought he was trying to
like not sewer himself but like the bed
scene with Rhonda when they were like oh
she's toxic
and then the scene in the room with the
boys where he was like she kissed me and
they're like oh like you're just a
wounded puppy we'll take you I didn't I
didn't know any of that until I watched
the show last week so that I was like
little but before the show came out like
I was more concerned that he was gonna
be mad about Corey and Kells dates so we
promised each other like okay no matter
what we see we're not gonna get grumpy
like we're gonna because obviously we're
not together right now so I can't like
hug him so we just promised each other
but he knew that that scene it was gonna
happen he didn't warn me so I was just
like of course I can't get mad about it
now
cuz it's been a year and everything
happened like that was at the very
beginning of the retreat like we weren't
as close you know what I mean like we
didn't really know each other that well
so he didn't really know me too much
like he was more concerned with being in
the group than he was with being with me
yeah but now you guys have been together
for almost a year cuz you filmed in
April right there is a anniversary there
is a lot of speculation that you and
Harry are either married or engaged and
I would just like you to speak on the
rumors please okay so there was photos
and videos of us that I was posting from
when we were in Ontario together
visiting my family and when we were
whatever whatever so we had promised
rings that we were wearing on our ring
finger that we both got so I think
everyone's like zooming in and being
occasionally I rang like we're not
married yet we're engaged he's asked me
to marry him a few times over the phone
and over Skype and he like we have a
shared folder called wedding rings and
it's really cute but I want to do it
properly like obviously I don't want to
get engaged or Xoom phone call until we
can like hang out but I was like because
work in quarantine and if the borders
are staying closed for a while I'm like
dead ass let's get married online so you
can come and then we'll do it official
again later but so you can come to
Canada like cuz that's the only way that
he can come here is it's like we're
spousal where is he yeah and he's
quarantined in LA hmm not terrible but I
I can't go there because he's not an
American citizen
wow this is very 90-day fiance I know
yeah Wow well I have a question for you
cuz because you and Harry like met in
this not um normal quote-unquote
situation does it affect your
relationship now like considering the
way that you met like things that you
learned on the show like do you guys
have more of an appreciation for being
able to touch each other because you
couldn't for so long yeah so when we
were finished filming and we got off the
retreat we were literally making out
every five seconds like I think you do
and I'm just like a minute of us kissing
like that is all we were doing we were
joined at the hip and of course now we
can't touch again so it's like we're in
the retreat basically only one way way
WAY worse because I can't even like put
them on the cheek so that's been really
hard but it just makes it honestly just
makes us appreciate appreciate each
other way more like
you and I don't take anything that I
have with him for granted that's so cute
and I have another question that was
really bothering me the whole time was
the money because obviously a hundred
thousand dollars sounds like a lot of
money but then at one point there was
thirteen people and it was just like
confusing as to whether or not everyone
was getting a hundred thousand we were
splitting it now you ended up splitting
it with with I think nine other cast
mates and I'm dying to know after taxes
what did you get um so I got because I'm
Canadian and the conversion rate like
the 35 percent or whatever u.s. is lower
I didn't up getting like $1,100 eleven
thousand oh my god oh that makes me feel
bad like that was well earned agreed
Nicole did not deserve it
neither did Chloe I said it was
frustrating as viewers like we saw Chloe
kissed some people that she was never
called out for like in the group with
Lana like even when she kissed um Bryce
I think she never got her comeuppance
was that just cut out because it like
wasn't as interesting or did you guys
ever really not know about that
I was getting in [ __ ] for everything I
was doing but everyone else was losing
money and it was literally like I was
kissing someone who I was [ __ ] in
love with basically he was just kissing
everyone to see if there was a
connection that's not the point of this
lady the point is to form the connection
and not kiss not to kiss to see if you
had intentionally hairy and I knew we
had a connection from day one
that's why it was so hard not to break
the rules could be new hearing at it so
yeah I was the only person that was
getting [ __ ] off for breaking like it
was like not even Harry Harry was
getting away with it like he would do
like that's what was really frustrating
for me to watch was like I felt like yes
you did cost the competition a lot of
money but it was like all for the
greater good like you were obviously
like having real feelings and like
really growing and connecting and it's
like Chloe was like the cool most
popular girl I'm like she kissed three
people um never made a connection never
got a second date and it's like why does
nobody care I think it's hard because I
did lose the most money so that
automatically makes them not like me but
yeah there's all those other kisses that
weren't even considered to be bad like I
lost a lot of money but the relationship
I have now is worth every penny and
other people that lost a lot of money
don't even talk so it's like what was
really worth what was going about Ronan
Rhonda are they still together
ooh sixteen thousand dollars down the
drain right totally yeah I was not more
than see it would be a shame if Harry
and I lost all this money and then we
weren't still together but we are and
like everyone else that lost the money
together don't damn can I take some
questions from Instagram we got so many
questions for you this is a great
question from SM Holmen when did you
guys eat did you have scheduled times to
hang out without the cameras rolling I'm
really curious about the food situation
was there a kitchen okay so the villa
came with this private chef and he was
in saying so every morning the alarm
would go off law no good good morning
whatever we would wake up there'd be a
spread of coffee and tea waiting for us
there would be this insane breakfast
spread of like waffles pancakes vegan
stuff for me fruit eggs and bacon for
the boys like massive spread of food and
then we would all eat and then we would
get ready for the day figure it was
going on and then around noon lunch same
thing so
different lunch spread every single day
we would have requests we they want
pizza we want lasagna we want deep fried
Oreos like the chef made everything and
then for dinner as well it was the same
situation so the craziest spread of food
and the mics we didn't have the mics on
during dinner time and there wasn't
cameras facing the table but there was
production standing around the table
making sure we didn't talk about
anything like sneaky and there was also
my tucked up too under the table so if I
said something like like you know what I
mean like they wanted to catch
everything and they didn't want anything
to be said that was juicy to not be on
the camera so we literally couldn't get
away with talking about anything like if
they heard us talking about something to
do see the production would come in like
literally set between us Wow and then
what about the showers because I
understand that they had cameras
everywhere they even caught you in the
middle of the night like making out with
Harry but what about the showers because
it's illegal to film someone in the
shower and then you could like
masturbate in the shower so there we had
keeper mics when we took our mics off to
shower we had to keep them right up
inside the shower door and those mics
were very very strong they could pick up
anything they picked it all up so there
was like an area of the shower that was
like frosted and I guess yeah but
private parts were not shown but you
could see the cameras could see our
heads and the cameras could see our feet
and there was like a frosted area that
you could that you couldn't see through
it but it was like if there was
hanky-panky going on it would have been
visible and the mics were also there to
pick up wow that's crazy
what did you do when they did a good job
of like logistical e organising the show
in some respects but if there's a season
two what do you think that they should
do differently and do you think that
they could get away with like a secret
of you can't obviously wouldn't be a
secret everything anymore everyone knows
this show yeah I don't think if there
was a season two that people would try
and get away with anything because
obviously Harry and I totally got away
with that I fully thought we got away
with it until he finished and I was like
yes and then she was like but I'm like
I'm like in my head I'm like I'm sorry
mom I'm sorry it
like so yeah I don't think if anyone
films it again like season 2 that
they're gonna try because it's just you
saw you couldn't get away with anything
and there was Mike's everywhere so that
was a question we got a lot for you is
did members of your family watch it did
you watch it with them was that weird so
all my family is in Ontario right now
I'm Vancouver and my mom messaged me and
she was like that you butt naked in the
shower like maybe and she's like are you
kissing a girl like maybe and then I
told my dad which parts to skip but I
think he just watched the whole thing
and he was just like you look beautiful
I'm proud of you and I was like thank
you like my parents are so supportive
and I actually they're super chill like
growing up they're really strict but now
they're just like we can't stop her
she's on a rampage so they just like
accepted and loved me and I told them
like no negativity please and they've
just been really supportive so that's
great
can you found my mom so what more could
they what more could anyone ask for and
you handle yourself so well everyone was
like an [ __ ] at times too and that's
the worst feeling in the world to feel
ostracized from a group of people so it
was not the easiest situation and you
like our everyone's favorite okay more
questions from Instagram we got so many
from Alexis bird was there anything on
the show that we didn't see that you
wish had aired I mean getting this
question a lot like um of course we were
there for a month so there was a lot of
stuff that um didn't wasn't shown but I
think there was a scene where Harry
asked me to be his girlfriend that I
really wanted to watch back but then I
was thinking about it and he asked me at
the night in the private suite when we
lost 20k and I'm pretty sure we were
naked so I was like but I'm like okay
that makes sense like I was expecting
after I saw the shower scene with Kells
obviously the scene with Harry and I
came later after I was like you see my
booty I'm like [ __ ] what are they going
to show from the private suite like I
was expecting the worst but thankfully
they didn't show the nitty gritty of
that because that was a really personal
cute moment so yeah um there the show
has blown up like exponentially
everyone's watching it you have 3
million followers on Instagram it's so
crazy who is like the coolest celebrity
that you know has watched the show or
they've tagged you in
I'm stories they follow you on Instagram
there's this
okay so ariana grande Halsey and she
followed my boyfriend followed my swim
label I'm and I'm like you were so sweet
thank you so much for the support she's
so cute I'm like what is life what is
this you have to send her a bathing suit
I know I want to but I don't want to I
want to but I'm just nervous like I
don't know like that's just like that's
crazy to me that she thought like she
wanted to follow me so I'm like that's
epic I know there's like this a lot of
Brazilian crazy Brazilian people like my
roommates presumably and she's like you
need to follow these accounts like
they're all blowing you up like there's
this account like 20 million followers
that's like daily posting like Goths
without the show and I know Harry had a
phone call with Justin Bieber yesterday
so I was like what is life like this is
not that's so crazy
would you ever move to LA um yeah I was
going to move there before quarantine
but now I have to wait but I definitely
want to be there for sure when this is
all over with Harry that's so exciting
well we just love you I could talk to
you all day you're literally so
beautiful like I want to look like you
in every way and I just want happiness
and love for you and thank you for being
so vulnerable honestly I feel like he
really opened up on the show and it
totally paid off like for the show you
made it show what it was also justice
for Haley because I don't think she got
a good at it but she seems like a
[ __ ] hilarious girl is she in love
with you not like not like relies be in
kind of love but we do love each other
like she had my back the entire time and
it just what her good qualities weren't
necessarily like highlighted you know
what I mean but she's an amazing person
she was she [ __ ] hilarious like
everything she said was just so honest
and she was just like so myself but like
I mean if people hate her they hate her
but she was just hilarious to me like I
loved everything she did same yeah I
didn't even think she got a bad edit I
thought she was [ __ ] hysterical and
when all the group is being like hurt
they were being heard mentality like
they were just being losers and she was
like you're all stupid I didn't want to
be here and I agree with her everyone is
so upset like oh you kiss so upset I'm
like guys two girls made out are you
really
I said about it like come on like yeah
and it was so funny
I'm curtayne yourselves like we're
entertaining ourselves like do something
like have fun yeah one last thing I just
need to know what eyeliner you were
wearing the whole season I actually I
think it was like Kat Von D that's what
I was doing my makeup like I looked some
scenes I'm like you oh so cakey like no
oh my god not at all
what foundation did you use um I I
literally use drugstore makeup like I
don't use anything too crazy I think it
was like fit me my fit need by
Maybelline but the laura mercier setting
powder is like what was the game change
everything I miss in the heat it was so
so so hot like the girls were full faces
every single day every single day and I
was like wow like it didn't make sense
to me like the the glam that went into
it like we were so hot but yeah laura
mercier setting powder did any of the
rooms have air conditioning yeah good
thank God in the bedroom when the guys
were doing their challenge I was like I
love that okay well everyone follow
Francesca even though she doesn't need
your followers because ariana grande
followed her and like what else matters
but it's Francesca farrago FA rhe oh we
love you thank you so much for being
here like this has been a dream and you
are so cute and pretty and we just want
you and Harry together forever like
you're the new Megan Marco maro